single biggest mistake i've made in my  career was not spending money  it's what put me in a position to be  able to buy real estate  because i had money but i had to buy the  real estate i had to use the money  bradley made a comment the other day  about money  money is not to be saved and hoarded  like like it's no good if you don't use  it  this is the problem with bitcoin  when did when do i transact with it  right i'm sitting on a million dollars  by the bitcoin right now  i can't get rid of it passed up i can't  go buy stuff with it so until that means  that that situation is resolved right  it's why people don't hold  gold anymore you don't keep gold because  you can't exchange it  money is to be used for those of you out  there that are like complaining about  the cost of anything the truth is that's  what that money's far  the only thing the only purpose money  has  is to be used